all right what's up everybody i'm here
with ethan and
we want to talk about bitcloud
everyone's talking about it already
we don't talk about it because you know
we don't really care if it's a scam we
don't care you can put your money where
you want
it's a speculative bet everyone knows
that um
but as something that relates to money
it also relates to reputation right
people are putting their reputations on
the line if they're on this platform
in some way uh how we're thinking about
it right
as we read through the one pager as we
do some of our own research
what kind of what ways are we thinking
about this what incentives are there
long term
um and we're just here to chat about it
because it's such a such an interesting
kind of viral topic and platform right
now so
um i guess we have the one pager up you
guys can't see it
but we're gonna walk through and comment
on it
so uh ethan you wanna give us a
start yeah sure so i'll say one other
thing too which is that uh the reason
this call came about is because
steph and i seem to have uh sort of a
contrarian opinion on this thing right
now
and i we we don't know why like it's
kind of funny we've been laughing about
it back and forth we're like what are we
missing here because everybody seems
to be super bullish on this but i keep
reading
through like like steph mentioned the
one pager or just looking at the numbers
as well
and i don't get it so uh quick
caveat like neither one of us are
blockchain experts
but um our full-time job is to kind of
like understand
businesses and markets and people and
stuff like that so
we're going to talk about this from that
perspective open to feedback
i want people to kind of come in and
explain to me what i'm not getting about
this
because so far this terrifies me like
it's like
this is like a let me off the rocket
ship kind of thing um and
we'll get into why but uh that's a quick
caveat i
i don't agree more i i have like alarms
going
off in my head when i and the more i
read into this but i also feel like
maybe we're missing something so let us
know if we are but yeah
let's jump in all right so uh the first
thing for anybody who hasn't heard of it
like what is bitcloud
i'm going to read the i'm going to read
a sentence or two out of the very
beginning of the white paper that kind
of explains it
but then i want to go a little bit
deeper and sort of pull back
the curtain on why their
explanation of what the platform is
might be different from
what the actual sort of eventual outcome
of the platform is so
there's a difference between what it's
being marketed as and like what it
really is
so uh from the white paper what is
bitcoin bitcloud is a new type of social
network that lets you
speculate on people and posts with real
money
and it's built from the ground up on its
own custom blockchain
uh so what does this basically mean what
it means is that
bitcloud's created a platform where
people are almost like stocks so
somebody like steph or me
or tim ferriss or chamath or anybody
else you can think of
can set up an account they can
basically make that thing public and
allow people to
buy and sell this digital coin that's
based on their reputation
and um steph i'm going to pause here for
a second to see if there's anything else
that you want to add to this but there's
a couple reasons why i'm like this is
there's more to this than beats the eye
to me and i i'm i'm
curious i don't think it's quite tell us
the whole story so is there anything
you said something important which is
it's kind of like a stock so some people
i don't even think big clout is
necessarily you know in their white
paper i don't see anything that says we
are the stock market for people i think
they were very
clear about that but then the natural
association that people have is to be
like this is the stock market for people
and one thing that's really important
there is it's not
right so normally when you have a stock
you have
actual ownership over something and that
ownership is very clear about what you
get right so
you get x type of voting rights or you
get dividends
or you also get the right to know what's
happening within that company right
through like public reports
um and that's not true with this so even
though there are certain mechanisms
where it's like yes
people have an asset that's based on a
person so it's kind of like a stock
it's not similar in that way that it
functions so
that's really important uh to call out
for sure
yeah that's a great point and there's
there's something else that like
grabbed my attention when i first read
this there's three things in this first
paragraph so i'm going to read the first
paragraph
uh from top to bottom so i think it's
two or three sentences
and then i'm just going to call out a
couple of things so it says bit clout is
a new type of social network that lets
you speculate on people and posts with
real money
it's built from the ground up as its own
custom blockchain its architecture is
similar to bitcoin
only it can support complex social
network data like
posts profiles follows speculation
features and much more at a
significantly higher throughput
and scale last sentence like bitcoin
bitclout is a fully open source project
there's no company behind it it's just
coins and code okay so three things that
jump out at me from this
which make me a little bit uh like
less enthusiastic or i just i find
myself questioning
so first of all it says you can
speculate on people and posts
and that's really interesting i don't
the speculating on people think makes
sense to me because
uh you know people can issue their coin
and
you can basically bet on whether or not
you think the value of that coin is
going to go up
what's unclear is what do they mean by
speculating on posts i
don't know and i'm curious to learn more
about that if anybody has any insight
there
but what's more important to me is this
thing about the speculation features in
general
uh right now i think a lot of the um
a lot of the excitement around bitco or
bitclout is
related to the values of all these
creators going up so people
um well for anybody who doesn't know the
company
basically scraped the top 15 000 twitter
accounts
and automatically created profiles for
them um
so they basically automatically issued
coins for the top 15 000 creators in the
world
out of the gate the value of all those
coins is going up right now
all right and that's exciting and i
think it's drawing a lot of attention
and a lot of people who are kind of
earlier making money
what i think is a little bit unclear at
this point is what they mean by these
speculation features
because uh the platform is unfinished so
one thing that steph mentioned early on
anybody who puts money in right now
there's no clear path to take money out
that's a feature that's
probably going to come
what i find myself wondering is what
other features are they going to build
into speculation
will it be possible to short people's
coins that's kind of the biggest concern
that i have because if it is
that opens up a series of incentive
problems related to
uh you're basically giving people an
incentive to
trash somebody else's reputation and i
think
to me stephanie curious to hear your
take on this but that's like for me
that's the biggest
uh drawback related to this right now is
that if those speculation features
include some kind of shorting
functionality
then there's not just an incentive for
somebody's reputation to go up
there's also incentive for the
reputation to go down
yeah i think so there are issues with
the platform as it exists today
you mentioned one there's no way to take
your money out currently
there's also issues with you know how
the platform was seated
and all that was a super smart growth
hack but you know parts of that were
actually illegal
right you like monetizing someone else's
identity without their permission
but let's just ignore those for the time
being and say you know there's problems
with the platform every platform starts
half-baked it may evolve
but to your point what i think people
haven't really like
thought far enough along with is like
what what does this turn into
right and of course right now it's small
it's invite only to some extent
um but as it evolves into something
perhaps meaningful right in size in
volume etc
you're gonna have different kind of
financial instruments created
and there are all these financial
instruments as it relates to
companies you know most people are
familiar with them with public companies
but what does it mean when that turns
into someone's reputation
right and of course any at least in
theory people
uh would be opting into this as they
joined the platform
but i don't think people really thought
about what it means to have people
betting on your reputation right to your
point like someone shorting
your reputation someone actually
creating things to manipulate
the world such that you look good or bad
of course some of those incentives exist
today but not with the same
um force i guess or the same kind of
perverse incentive where there's money
behind it and then you start to get into
questions like okay so if i created a
bitcloud coin right and i and i opted
into the platform and eventually i
realized
well you know this isn't working for me
people are shorting my coin they're
talking they're making up stories about
me that aren't true
my own following is upset because they
bought into this and my coin is going
down
and they no longer trust me how do i opt
out that's another thing that i
you know maybe they will find a
mechanism where this works but i don't
think people have thought
into those aspects of the platform right
when when you join twitter or when you
join patreon or sub stack
you have an agreement that's very clear
as to what someone's getting
and what they're not getting and you can
end that contract
right when once you've created a coin a
big clout coin a crater coin
and it's out there it's unclear how that
relationship can ever end
right and if it does end if there is a
hard
stop at some point you know someone's
gonna be holding the bag
right because all of a sudden that coin
doesn't exist and it's just gonna be a
race to trade out of it
as soon as people possibly can so to
your point i just don't think
um i don't know if creators joining the
platform have thought through
what they're really opting into right
and
we had talked about this before ethan
but you made a great point which is
basically like
someone opting into this is putting
their reputation
at risk in some way and the actual big
clout platform has no
um they're not really putting up any
risk right
it's they're basically offloading the
risk onto a creator that's opting into
sharing this with their audiences
even past that if we just talk about
like what someone gets
if they buy into a crater coin um
again some people i think a lot of
people understand what it is today
but it is not an isa it's not a stock
right so you're not actually buying into
um the future income or creations of
that creator
you are buying into their reputation
which is a vague kind of
amorphous thing um but that's fine
there's a lot of amorphous things that
people buy into and it doesn't need to
be necessarily like a physical good
but as you're buying into this one of
the things that you mentioned before
ethan is this idea that um you know you
may also be able to buy
or buy and sell trade uh posts and
things like that
i actually think that what they're
getting at there is for example if
someone owns a chemoth coin
maybe chamoth opens up the door for
anyone who owns this coin
to be able to dm him or to
access his his special newsletter or
something like that
i think there's merit to that but what
doesn't bake out for me there is as soon
as you start to
incorporate those things i think it
actually undermines this
very amorphous thing that is reputation
because we can all kind of
vaguely say we think chamas you know his
market cap
at least on big club today is let's see
i think it's like 40 something million
dollars and you know you can be like
okay that sounds right like he's he's
important he
he's well known um oh sorry it's 14
million dollars currently um but
that's fine and you can buy into that
but as soon as you start to be like
hmm um he's offering dms for example
as as kind of something that rewards his
his coin owners
the math doesn't bake out right and i
think it actually again undermines the
concept where all of a sudden you're
like okay she wants a busy guy maybe he
can
he can kind of be willing to
dm five people a day at the current
market cap you're looking at like a
single dm
being worth like ten thousand dollars
right and then all of a sudden i think
people owning it are like
okay like this is not worth the money
right so i think you either have to keep
it as this amorphous thing that is
reputation or it basically becomes like
a patreon or a sub stack
where it's very clear like value for
value and as soon as you start blending
the two i think you actually
just confuse people and undermine the
original concept
for sure this is one of the things that
i
am also a little bit confused on and so
look we could talk about it
through the perspective of of an example
so
sean curry who's am i saying his last
name right is it pure i think it's curry
i'm not sure
john the co-host of the my first million
podcast
really successful guy he's put a lot of
effort into building his reputation
and you two were having an exchange on
twitter yesterday which is really
interesting
so far sean's pretty bullish on this
thing and
um i think i understand his his take he
has a couple of
uh points that he made and he says
something along the lines of like
okay well here's why this is cool it's
because as a creator i get to monetize
my reputation building so it's not just
it's i'm not just monetizing at the end
it's like if i'm becoming more and more
popular
my personal value is growing along the
way and i i think
if i had to guess why people are bullish
on this now i think
a lot of them are kind of thinking the
same thing it's this
appears to be a win for creators because
you're no longer building your
reputation for free somehow monetizing
that
what confuses me though or or what i
would push back on is
is the idea that um
there's two things to your point
a lot of the features that are mentioned
in this white paper are things that
actually already exist and point number
two
is in my opinion this platform
increases your risk and exposure as a
creator
so i think it actually like i don't
think the value it creates
is worth the risk to your reputation
especially given that there are other
ways to capture this
this value elsewhere so i'll give you a
quick example i'm just going to run
through it
um continuing through the white paper
what the authors have said is like okay
what are creator coins useful for
there's a few things one they say the
stakeholder meeting so you could
like you said uh you could basically
meet
directly with people who hold your coin
okay that's a cool idea
uh a new way to prioritize messages so
you could rather than having
like this huge inbox that's just
overflowing with people you could say
just show me
the messages from people who like own
10 or more of my coins or something like
that you can prioritize
based on ownership that's interesting
sponsored posts
premium content paid likes okay
i get it these are all legitimate ideas
but here's the thing
you can already do all this on other
platforms right like i already have a
way to do a stakeholder meeting through
something
like patreon to your point or sponsored
posts so it says right here
creators have an inbox where anyone can
bid to have them repost
a particular post so if you want kim
kardashian to retweet your fashion brand
you submit an entry to her inbox and if
she retweets it she keeps your money
great but that's already happening like
that already happens they've streamlined
it a little bit here
but here's the big question they've
at what cost have they streamlined it
the cost is
the whole world can now gamble on your
reputation and i don't
know that long-term creators are going
to see the extra value in that when they
could just be
doing this you know through other
avenues last thing i'll say about this
too the last thing they say
one of the features is money likes so
likes can be reimagined as purchases of
the creator's coin so it costs money to
like something
i get that like
technically speaking that's a feature
that could be implemented
but i i think my personal opinion that
i think people are overestimating
followers willingness to pay to like
content like there's a reason facebook
and twitter are free
it's not that they haven't thought of
monetizing those like buttons
it's that i i just sincerely don't think
most
followers would do that so legitimate
uses for this and i can see why people
are excited about it but
i have to question long term whether or
not the audience engagement is there and
and whether creators will really find
value in this given the trade-offs
uh and the risk that you face just to
comment on that so
there to your point a lot of these
features exist in other places and
people could argue oh well as you kind
of
aggregate them into one platform that's
really interesting but i actually
to what i was saying earlier i think
that actually undermines aspects of it
right so if you're just trading on
reputation and you don't have any sort
of
direct relationship of like i give you x
and you pay y
then again this amorphous thing i don't
i don't personally want to participate
because we've talked about some of the
like negative long-term consequences of
people actually betting on your
reputation
but as soon as you start to introduce
stuff that's more like something like
sub stack or patreon
where people again it's like a trade of
a very clear value
um the economics no longer makes sense
because of the
bonding curve that exists within
bitcloud
right so there's only going to be a
certain number of people if people
aren't familiar within bitcloud
every time additional bitcloud is
purchased it's done at an
at a higher price right and there's
going to be uh just a limit
to which people are going to be willing
to spend
on your newsletter right or like to get
a dm from you
right and so it just like that actual
relationship
may sound interesting at first because
you're like it you incorporate scarcity
and you
actually reward early early people who
buy into you
but it starts to degrade really really
quickly um
for something like this right so i don't
think people have thought about that and
then the other part is
again i think big cloud has some really
interesting ideas and if you were to
take it and adjust it in certain ways
and they'll talk about this
it may make sense but the part that i
think people are missing is like you
have marketplaces for certain things
like companies because
of course companies die but companies
tend to last for quite some time and
even within
like as a creator myself i can create
something like a book that will outlast
me and can actually have a shelf life
for a very long time
if you look at history in you know any
sort of sense
people's reputations are fragile and
um short-lived quite frankly and and
that's without these kind of
extended incentives to actually
manipulate
that right and so it's very rare even
top celebrities you know maybe their
shelf life is is a couple decades but
most of them it's you know a couple
years max and then creators themselves
again like
you think about who your favorite
creator is today it's probably not the
same creator as a year ago or three
years ago
and so betting on people people's
reputations
is a little maybe silly is not the right
word but
i think of it as like betting on a stock
that you know will almost certainly go
to zero
within the next couple years right yeah
totally i think this is a really
important point that isn't for whatever
reason isn't being discussed widely
enough like
let's let's assume for a second that
eventually there's a there's the ability
to short these coins right now i don't
think it's possible
uh and it may be that the platform
doesn't intend to build that
ability at all but even if the platform
doesn't people
like if if there is incentive to create
a monetary instrument like that someone
will create it
right yeah i agree with you there so if
we assume for a second that that
is the case then let's look at like
statistically what's the smartest play
for an investor what's more likely that
somebody's reputation is going to
continue to go up
forever or that they will eventually be
canceled especially in today's
yeah i mean it's it's i feel like it's
in inevitable for large
people with large followings to
eventually be cancelled exactly and
which means that
under you know if we assume that uh some
sort of shorting instrument becomes
possible then the smart money
in my opinion is to bet against
everybody like
the smart money is on is actually
against most reputations these days
so uh it's kind of like when you think
about it so
the stock market over time is is
expected to continuously go up
right if you're talking about like an
index like the s p um and that's why
in general you you want to bet
on stocks and not against them but to
your point this is almost like the
alternative right like the opposite
where the
the trend line of what most people not
all people will tend to go to zero
right um in terms of their reputation so
to your point it's like actually betting
on this
maybe the same way that getting or
shorting a stock can provide you some
short-term return
um and you can be speculative and when
in the long term
if you're betting on these things you're
probably gonna lose
right and if you look at like just the
way that options work
the the potential upside on shorting
could be significantly higher than even
owning your stock in the first place
and i just think this becomes much more
complicated
when you introduce large financial
incentives
for tanking somebody's reputation so
that aside i want to dig into something
that you also mentioned
uh which is the like the actual
math on how these coins values change
over time because
here's so i mentioned before one thing
that i understand is the
the enthusiasm that this could somehow
fund a creator's career right
because you're being in this space i
know how hard it is to make money from
an audience
and uh also just like really care about
creators want to see them succeed
so i get i get the enthusiasm for sure
um for anybody creating like i'm sorry
continuing through
the white paper one of the things that
they talk about is the creator coin
supply
curve so the value of these coins
doesn't actually change based on
perceived value of the creator
it's not a direct correlation right the
value of the coins
goes up and down based on the supply
alone when somebody buys your coin new
coins are minted
and the price of the coins goes up and
when they sell your coins those coins
are destroyed the price of the coins
goes down
uh what that means is that there's a
very predictable
price for uh the coin
depending on how much has been minted
you can literally tell me
what somebody's market cap is today and
i can tell you exactly how many coins
are in circulation for them
it has it has which means two things one
this isn't really based on reputation
it's based on
i guess supply um
and two it means that you can actually
do some math related to how many
of these coins you have to sell in order
to make a certain amount of money so i
want to talk about
two situations in particular one is
uh what it takes to make about a hundred
grand on this as a creator
now there are different ways to do this
uh there are some things that are
interesting about this platform so one
is that as a creator you have the
ability to
set a percentage of the supply that you
automatically get and what happens then
is like
you can set it i think it's you can set
it at anything but they suggest 10
what means what that means is of all the
coins that are purchased
10 percent go straight to you so if
somebody comes and buys 100 coins
you automatically get 10 of them and uh
that's one way to do this the other way
is to set it to zero
zero percent and then buy a bunch of
your own coin yourself
uh so that just that your own value in
your holdings
goes up as other people buy
two important things or one important
thing to know about this is that
and for whatever reason this isn't
widely discussed creators
they they only get uh
paid on net coin sales what that means
is that
if i come and buy a hundred coins and
then sell 100 coins
you actually don't get any if you have
your
even you know if you have your creator
percentage set to anything
right uh there has to be a net purchase
of your coins in order for you to be
paid
what's unclear inside the white paper is
whether or not that
changes or well two things it's unclear
what time frame
they're calculating that net purchase
based on right
so this is maybe it's hourly maybe it's
daily maybe it's monthly maybe it's
yearly i don't know it's it's
not stated but what that means is like
you know let's say it's let's say it's
daily there could be tons of trade
volume on you
across the course of a day and you don't
benefit at all if it's if it's net zero
if it's monthly or longer then again
you're not really benefiting from this
as a creator if if it ends up being net
zero
so there needs to be some clarity around
how quickly that percentage is actually
calculated for the creator in order for
me to believe that this is
a benefit to creators themselves rather
than just the people behind the platform
here's the thing that's
uh i think is interesting so if you
let's say you set your percentage to ten
percent
all right based on the economics of the
coin if you want to make a hundred
thousand dollars then that means you
have to have 132
coins sold uh at that point
your coin would be worth about seven
thousand six hundred dollars
and uh people would have pumped about
000 into your stock
as a as a creator so here are a couple
of things that i think are interesting
i agree that that is exciting
on the surface right that you could make
a hundred grand
from people speculating on that but i
think there's a question here which
is if you can get people to spend 339
000 on you do
are you capitalizing at the highest
possible rate
and is there a better way for you to
capture more of that directly from your
supporters
than to allow them without risking your
reputation yeah then to allow them to
bet on you exactly that's what i'm
thinking of right now
yeah i think a couple thoughts there is
just
you're right that right now in in
being able to reap the rewards of being
a creator on the platform
you need to basically you need to push
someone to buy
your coin which is what their incredible
growth hack
right you've got to give them kudos such
a great growth hack of preceding the
platform although
partially illegal what they did we
should say
um partially legal but incredible growth
hack but that is basically what's
happening right that's what's pushing
people to the platform but
just remember there's these incentive
structures where as a creator
think about like as a creator today ask
yourself the question
like would i shall would i sell my uh
supporters a shitty
product right and some creators are cool
with that and there's mlm schemes and
all that stuff but
most creators would be like no i care
about how my
audience views me because i have a
long-term relationship with them that i
hope to keep
right and as soon as you start pumping
them into this reputation scheme and you
no longer have control right because i
have control when i say
hey steph smith audience i want to sell
a book and i and i've created it and i
understand what's in it and i think it's
valuable right as soon as you start
trading on this reputation mechanism and
especially if you're the one
pushing people to actually buy into this
then if it crashes which again we talked
about
reputation life cycles are short so it's
not guaranteed but it's
i would say likely then you have
in some way probably sold
your audience to this what i would call
potentially a shitty product
right people may view this differently
but that's kind of how i'm thinking
about it
as a creator where i want to only push
my audience to buy things
or to monetize them in some way but i'm
proud
of what they're getting from it right
and of course people can say speculators
can speculate whatever right but there
is
there is something really important here
that um it's different if big clout is
pushing people to buy crater coins
versus if they're now kind of offloading
that task
which is again their genius growth hack
onto other people
to do this for them right um and i don't
think or maybe they are and they're okay
with it but i what i would just
encourage if you're a creator listening
to this is like
if if you're creating coin and pumping
it to your audience that is what you are
doing
um you may think it's actually a good
investment and if they're early they can
make money off
okay cool but just know that you
are selling something to your audience
right and that's why where i think this
does differentiate between something
like a twitter
right and something where there's actual
financial incentives
for sure and and the interesting to me
like the interesting thing about what
you're saying is that
this isn't just your audience these are
your biggest fans these are the people
who are
literally willing to put their money on
your reputation the ones you you have to
take care of the most
right so it's it's this very complicated
scenario where the people who you're
supposed to protect the most are the
ones who
stand to lose the most if an outside
force
takes an interest in your stock price
and this is not there's not just not a
lot you can do to control it so it's
a very complicated situation now let's
talk about this super quickly can you
give the analogy of the icos because
that's basically what it is because
just when it's positioned this thing has
been positioned so many different ways
and
that's partially because it's still kind
of half baked and things are being
worked out and
and it may evolve into other things but
at least as to like what it is today
i thought what you said about it was so
spot-on in terms of what this
really is at least so far yeah sure so
on paper and again i i think one of the
reasons that
bitclout has been so successful is
because they are master marketers
like i don't approve of it but it's kind
of like when your kid gets in trouble
and you're like i don't have a kid but
like you gotta know when kids get
involved without them right
yeah yeah you're like oh you're in so
much trouble but i get it as well like
nice job buddy
you know yeah i don't so i don't i don't
approve
of what they did but they but it's a
smart growth hack the other thing is
that they're positioning
this product in a very smart way where
the reality of what it is has been
abstracted away so what this what this
is on paper
is they've basically done 15
000 icos without the permission
of the people who are backing those
coins right by scraping twitter and
creating an account for the top 15
000 people they've created they've done
15 000 icos
and now they're basically just trying to
get people to buy into those icos and i
think anybody who's thinking of
getting into this either as a creator or
an investor which should ask themselves
you know one as a creator would i create
an ico for myself if the answer is no
you know think twice about just because
someone did it for you doesn't mean
you know all of a sudden it's a good
idea yeah and then similarly like as a
as a backer
would i buy so-and-so's ico it starts to
kind of break down because like when you
think about this is
betting on somebody's reputation that's
one thing you're like oh okay well
you know somebody like kim kardashian or
tim ferriss or steph smith these are all
people that i think are
doing interesting work and are probably
going to become more
popular on this platform so if i'm early
i should buy in
but you have to ask yourself the real
question which is like if
you know if i issued an ico tomorrow
would you buy it
probably not but what the platform's
done is
aggregate thousands of icos and make it
extremely easy to issue a new one which
could be useful like there's there's
potential there
but let's not let's not mince words
about what it is these are just icos
that's literally all they are so um
i think that's an interesting way of
looking at it one other thing that's
really
important related to what i was talking
about earlier is like how you actually
capture value from this
as a creator so in the example that i
gave um
you know if you wanted to say build a
hundred thousand dollars in value you'd
have to have
roughly 132 of your coins sold
at that rate again the the the value of
each coin would be about 7 600 bucks
now what happens when you want to take
your money out so he and
again this is an example that sean gave
and i think it's a good one this is like
he said um and i'm paraphrasing
let's say i want to take a year off and
just work on you know creating or take
some time off something like that i can
cash out of my ico
or my coin and uh
go do that right okay so if you've
gotten yourself to the point we have a
hundred thousand dollars
in this in value in order to get any
money from that you now have to sell you
just sell your coins if your coin is
trading at seven
seven thousand six hundred bucks which
it will be that's a
concrete number you can't change it um
oh actually no i'm sorry i'm wrong these
figures are based on the current
cost of bit clout so if bitcloud goes up
your coin could be trading it
considerably more but
current cost um
you would have to sell a hundred
thousand dollars worth of your coin at
seven thousand bucks a pop
you're talking about selling around 10
or 12
coins which would be most of your
holdings as a creator
what the curious thing about this is is
that with only 130 coins
issued if you then sell 10 or 12 of them
you're destroying
roughly 10 of the uh stock
and the value of your ice of your coin
will go down by 10
so here's where this becomes a dangerous
thing i think is if this
actually takes off it's like a
legitimate way to gauge
somebody's reputation what happens when
you want to pull your value out and all
of a sudden the market sees your
reputation go down by 10 percent
maybe nothing happens maybe people buy
in maybe people start looking more
trying to figure out why your reputation
is tanking and they start finding
reasons
i don't know but it just doesn't seem
like
uh it seems like something that creators
should at least be thinking about right
because there are better ways to make a
hundred thousand dollars at least
there's other ways
to make a hundred thousand dollars yeah
there was a tweet in response to some of
the conversation that was happening and
um this guy john basically said
the bonding curve encourages creators to
pump and dump their own reputation i
know creators who have bought
up their own big clout cheap and then
dumped it on later investors
horrific incentive structure right so
again it's this idea we're like sure you
can
you can make money off of this right
there there's
endless ways especially if you're early
to make money off of this but
just remember that even though this
seems like an easy way to make money
anything where you make money there
there is a cost
right and in this case part of that cost
is your reputation if it's your own coin
right and i'm not just talking about the
like philosophical reputation but people
if you pumped to buy your coin who did
it and put their real money into this
and you end up selling because you want
to
net that profit they lose money one
quick question though i had is in the
same way that there's
and this is like a genuine question i
don't know the answer in the same way
there's a bonding curve where the more
um the more demand there is and people
buying the coin the price of the coin
goes up
as you sell the price of the coin goes
down right um yep
okay and is it also that same
exponential relationship where
well the reason i'm asking because you
said if you sell 10
of the coins wouldn't it actually go
down more than 10
in value it would go down exponentially
the same way that it went up
exponentially
yeah so this is this is something that's
a little bit unclear i can tell you what
they say
in the white paper so
give me one second to find this okay so
it says uh
buying creates coins well and while
buying creates coins while pushing the
price up and locking money into the
profile while selling destroys coins
while pushing the price down and
unlocking money from the profile okay
this means
this means a couple of things first of
all and again this is something that's
kind of unclear based on the way this is
written
how much value do you get to hold on to
as a creator if
let's say you have your your your
percentage set to 10
if people sell your coin does that money
disappear from your account i think it
yes
no it does so that's what i'm saying you
own a certain number of coins and
what i'm trying to get at is this just
as quickly as
a coin goes up in value from what i
understand about the way this bonding
curve works
it goes down in value right so if you
sell a coin
at seven thousand the next coin you're
selling isn't at seven thousand
and if you said sell ten percent of the
coins that ten percent is actually going
to reduce the price of coins by more
than ten percent i don't i can't do the
math on that in my head
but it's going to be a lot more than ten
percent you're yeah you're absolutely
right so i've got
i've got the chart here and the uh just
to give you the idea so if you're at 132
coins which is about
like based on today's prices where you
need to be to make 100 grand
as a creator your coin would be selling
for 7 600
if you then sell 13 of those
in order to capture your money right
that would bring you down to 119 coins
and it would be going for 6 hundred so
that's a difference of fourteen hundred
bucks
which is about twenty percent right
exactly
yeah so i mean one of the things that
this kind of makes me think of is just
sure it's great to be early to a
platform this is not investment advice
obviously if people want to speculate go
speculate i don't
have a problem with that it's more so
just be aware
of i guess the difference between
is this platform providing value to
people and therefore they're engaging
or is it set up in a way that where
they've just done some excellent growth
hacks they have
excellent kind of incentive structures
to get people to want to participate
um like which one of those is happening
and really
i mean it may be some combination of the
two but just remember like
right now the the door is closed you
can't exit so the price is only going to
go up right now
right people know this but that's
something really important to keep in
mind
in addition you have all these people
who they've incentivized
by preceding their accounts who are now
sharing it with the platform but it's
early days right so
you don't have the the kind of
negative stories that i think will come
right everyone right now is making money
everyone right now um has people who are
excited
and they're cr their their audience is
excited because they've told them about
this thing
and more people are rushing in and you
know at least for now they're making
money and again
i think there's totally an argument to
the fact that you can make money off of
this platform today and there's there's
a reason to speculate on it potentially
but
just keep in mind that the structure
that it is
today is is just it's only going to go
up
today so that's why people are excited
that's why people are telling other
people about it
of course these short the short term is
very clear to me
in terms of what will happen but really
what we've been talking about is like
you know what happens when those stories
start coming coming out and some creator
you know just told their their audience
to buy this thing
and they're left holding the bag how
does that creator look right
how does it look once a creator decides
to exit the platform we finally see what
that
that looks like as an example we were
talking about this earlier but
i was actually one of the people that
was not part of the original 15k
but someone decided so outside of the
15k you can just create an account
and someone i guess impersonated me
right they took my
stepsmith io handle they put my picture
in the same bio for my twitter um and i
was like how can this be
and it's because anyone can just create
an account today so that's something
that they'll probably fix
but i emailed them and you know to their
credit big clout actually took it down
i will say they took it down without
verifying who the hell i was right so
so someone could have just done that to
another person's account as well
but there was not much but thousands of
dollars worth of big cloud at least in
theory within this
this coin what happened to it right we
haven't even seen what happens to
um these systems because we were only in
this like exciting growth stage
of like because it's literally geared
where it can only grow
right there's no backdoor there's
there's nothing that can happen today
that would be negative but as soon as
those things start to happen
i just i i guess we're just encouraging
people to think past this early growth
stage
and think about where does this platform
actually extend to
because it's not as simple as as like
what
it seems to be today for sure
yeah i think there's a very um
lopsided view of what this actually is
in in large part
because of what you're talking the
gearing and also in in small part
because of the the network effects of
the way it was launched like
a lot of the people who are on this
platform know each other they're all
friends
and the only people who have access
right now are like friends and super
fans
right so it's all just kind of a party
everyone's having a lot of fun with it
what happens everyone's happy when
they're making money until they aren't
right yeah
exactly and the other interesting thing
is that this is okay it's worth
it's worth discussing this by the way we
don't want to turn this into like a hate
fest so
after totally we want to get into some
of the the legitimate uses and like
where we
what we would need to see in order to be
more bullish on this um
but it's worth pointing out too to
anybody who's a creator
this is not this is not geared towards
your happiness like we
there's a so there's already an example
of um
of this playing out once once
you open yourself up to be better on by
the world the only incentive is for
people to make money they
they they may like some may buy your
coin in order to support you to show
support
uh but major players and
i guess i'll say that's certainly not
the incentive for everyone
the major incentive is to make money
regardless of whether or not you
are happy and so we saw kind of a funny
version of this play out recently where
ryan beagleman was on the um the my
first million podcast ryan's a friend of
the show
he's a really interesting guy he's built
some successful media companies and he
was early to bit clout
and so he was the one who was kind of
brought on as like one of the one of the
experts on this to talk about it and
while he was on there like
so ryan and sean are bullish sam was a
little late to the party and he was kind
of
he was asking questions and he wasn't
really sold on it
um and ryan was
kind of trying to stir the pot a little
bit like he was he was trying to get sam
to uh take on austin from
the uh morning brew and see who could
get their value to be higher
again just friendly competition ryan's
friends with both sam and austin and
he's invested in both those guys
so not a big deal but the question is
like first of all
sam said something which was small
but i think important which is like he
just said
i don't want to do that he's like i've
made my money man like i don't want to
take on this competition now
and like like you know he's got no
reason to compete with austin
over reputation but everybody who
invests in those stocks
has incentive for them to do that right
so in this case it was a
it was like an example of friends just
kind of bantering but what happens all
of a sudden when larger money moves in
and and has the exact same incentives
they they don't
they are not set up to care about your
happiness the same way that your friends
are and right now the whole platform is
mostly friends
uh and fans so i think that's extremely
lopsided and is creating a different
image of this thing than will ultimately
play out to be
um just gonna quickly add on
this idea that like right now the
platform is benefiting from
people with large audiences and to your
point
these people have money right if
anything the thing that they
um want to retain is their reputation
and how they're viewed in the world
right because they already have enough
money
to last them their lifetime um and
i think what we're going to see quite
frankly is that
as some of the negative aspects of this
platform potentially
emerge these people are going to be like
i don't i don't need this
right like i've got what i need and why
am i putting my
reputation on the line where people can
or have these incentives to um or
additional incentives
i should say because there are
incentives already on certain other
platforms but additional
more concrete incentives to take someone
down i just
or manipulate their reputation both
positively or negatively they're just
like i don't i don't need this right and
these people
already pay tons of money to be seen
positively in
in different ways whether it's like
buying art or wearing certain things or
being on certain shows or
hanging around with peop certain people
and
i think they're just gonna be like this
doesn't make sense for me and that is
big cloud's ability to
um at least today grow and i think
that's actually going to
reverse at some point when people start
to say i don't want this anymore
for sure it's like their their genius is
also their downfall in that they
they they conscripted 15 000 of the most
influential people in the world
in the beginning it's like you you could
not have a better marketing team
out there right but you also couldn't
have a worse
enemy and as soon as as if like you said
if hypothetically people find that this
just isn't worth the upside
then i think they're going to start
encouraging their audiences to take to
get off the platform
and that could spell at the end for this
now
it's possible that that's all it needs
like like you and i mentioned there are
some legitimate use cases for this and
maybe all it needs is a little bit of
time to develop
the more legitimate sides and you know
in five years from now
like we won't be talking about big clout
as a betting platform but
the underlying infrastructure which is
more important we'll still be around
if that's the case great but i think
it's a different conversation than
whether or not this really is the future
of reputation management
and by the way i mean to your point
managing your reputation
is hard enough without like incentives
for other people to manipulate it so i
don't i don't i just don't see why
people who can make
you know significantly more money on
their own will continue
to do this but i could be wrong i mean
here's the other thing we're ready to be
wrong here
um and and this is certainly not like a
black or white this is absolutely gonna
happen
it's more so us being like have people
thought of this
right and maybe they have and maybe
they're just like we're cool with this
or
or i actually think that's probably
unlikely to happen or whatever but
i do think there's a portion of people
who haven't thought through like
what incentives exist or will exist
given this structure and how will that
evolve over time i just really think to
your point like
their excellent marketing is also
just not going to work over time right
and it's actually going to reverse in
some way where
the people who grew the platform are
just going to be they're so important
or i shouldn't say important so wealthy
and and have reputations already they're
gonna say i don't want this i don't
i don't want to risk this or add these
additional incentives when i don't need
to
so let me ask you a question then
because uh i think it's important to be
or we both think it's important to be
balanced here we we've talked about this
a lot we're like how are we going to
make this not just like
a hate fest on bitcloud because we have
some legitimate ideas here
okay so i have a question which is what
would you
need to see in order to believe the
opposite
like what would you need to see in order
to reverse your current opinion
on the platform and think that it's
actually a benefit long term
yeah it's a great question and totally
agree with you if people are listening
i i think in most cases you want
excuse me a platform to succeed right
any sort of innovation
tends to be good i just think if you
think about it like a spectrum
where anything that you create is gonna
at least at first be half baked
but on one side of the spectrum you're
talking about like putting up like a gif
online
which is just for fun who cares if it's
half big it's not hurting anyone and
then maybe on the other
end you've got like a vaccine or
something like that we're just like this
cannot be half baked right if you're
injecting this into someone
this matters do not mess it up and then
this isn't somewhere in between
right and the reason that i think it
skews more towards
um getting this right is because
people's reputations are all they have
right i mean of course you have assets
and stuff but
um this is the only thing that will
carry with me from
the day i'm born until the day i die is
my reputation
everything else comes and goes
relationships people assets
um and that matters my reputation
matters
in terms of my ability to build an
audience to be wealthy to be happy
right all of us you know whether you
want to deny it or not like the way that
people perceive us matters to some
extent and then on top of that you're
laying on not just reputation but money
right so anything that
relates to people's finances and
investing also needs to be a little less
half-faked
right a little more baked so to your
point
i think there are ways that if bitcloud
could evolve
and be less half-baked in certain areas
there's something here although i don't
think it looks quite like
bitcoin does today so some of the things
are that i think this idea of trading on
people's reputations
if you're gonna do it it needs to be um
well it needs to be regulated in some
way and i'm not talking about like the
sec or something like that but
it needs to be opt-in right fully opt-in
right now they're they're seating of 15
000 people
incredible growth hack borderline or
maybe fully illegal
right um so that needs to be it can only
be opt-in
and you should need to be able to verify
that this person
is the person that they are and then on
top of that there needs to be very clear
outlines of what happens if this person
no longer wants to participate
right because i do think that's a very
very
likely scenario for some people at least
the second
is if you you could keep it as this
vague amorphous thing like reputation
but i think that starts to falter
because again it i think it
it's hard to understand what that is and
maybe that's okay but what i do think
makes sense is right now they have this
kind of amorphous like is it reputation
is it your betting on posts can you can
you know creators can make
like pick and choose what they get well
if that's the case and the marketplace
itself should be very clear about what
people are getting with a certain coin
right today it's nothing but if you're
gonna create it then
maybe certain creators have more of an
isa maybe certain creators do have the
ability to like
you know have one-to-one conversations
with their audience but then you start
to get more into like again
things that exist like a patreon or a
sub stack just that happen to be built
on
the blockchain um so that's important
just clear terms
that doesn't exist today and i think it
should
and then the third is just transparent
marketing
right and so i think most people have
caught on to this idea at this point
that
bitcloud is not or i should say crater
coins are not really equivalent to
a stock but that is important because if
people are buying in and thinking that
they're getting anything
in return for buying into this creator
other than just speculating on their
reputation then i don't think that's
right and again in certain circumstances
you saw um
certain things like this happen at the
beginning of twitter right
um where they appreciated platforms or
people were pretending to be other
people but again when you're talking
about people's reputations
and then on top of that people's
finances i just think it
it's got to be more clear right you
can't have people saying this is a stock
market for creators
when it's when that's confusing right
and misleading for people
in understanding what they're actually
buying for sure i totally agree if you
were
if you were to ask me like what would it
take for me to be
pro bitcloud fully agree it's gotta be
opt-in
absolutely has to be opt-in if you want
to participate in this by all means i
would never stop somebody
it seems crazy but like hey you do you
you know if this if this seems like a
fun way or exactly
that's fine but it's got to be opt-in
and it's got to be controlled like right
now
everybody has like everybody if you are
making your money online
or if you have an online presence at all
which is
you know most of the world at this point
you now have to protect against this
because it's not opt-in it is opt-out
can we just talk about that
real quick before you go on with my case
in that scenario
when i tweeted about you know someone
impersonating me or whatever you want to
call it um
certain people were saying you know
steph like you should just create your
own big clout
so that you just let your audience know
hey this is me
not this one i don't want to do that
like i shouldn't have to
and again if people want to participate
go participate like this is not a
conversation about like
what people should or shouldn't do but
if i personally
as a creator don't want to participate
my
course of action shouldn't just be okay
go you have to participate to block
other people from impersonating you
right
for sure i i was thinking about this
yesterday i actually think there's a
really
big opportunity here for some crypto law
firm to get involved
because at this point and again i'm i'm
nobody i
like i'm just i have a tiny tiny
audience just kind of starting down this
trail
but i wouldn't want to have to think
about this and i think there's an
opportunity
where law firms or talent agencies could
basically
i don't know if it would be an issue a
token or what but
charge to to do reputation management on
this and basically police these
platforms to make sure that your your
identity is not being used on them i
think there's a huge opportunity there
even if uh you know big clout
eventually pivots unfortunately i think
this is the kind of genie that can't
just be put back into the bottle
there are whole blockchain is open
source meaning even if they
change it it wouldn't take much for
somebody else to spin up something
similar so
we now live in a world where it's
possible to
spin up a betting platform based on
people's appear like
appearance and reputation you can't just
undo that so
there is some kind of opportunity here
for law firms to get involved
uh which i thought i'd call out and then
to your point like this shouldn't be
something that people
have to opt into in order to protect
themselves from
so that would be one major thing
opt-in i like your idea of transparency
and then related to this i think this
rolls up into transparency but
the founders have got to have some skin
in the game so like this
here's the thing that's one of the
things that's crazy to me
this platform was built by a
pseudonymous founder so
you know people say that they know the
person behind it maybe they do maybe
they don't
but at the end of the day the person who
built this
has no potential downside for their own
reputation
on this platform and like one of the
things that's kind of funny i told you
about this yesterday stuff but i'll just
tell everybody listening like
people are already tweeting there's this
tweet from um
uh michael arrington who is the founder
of
techcrunch he basically said you know
psa bitcloud is not
there's a there's a twitter account
that's now trolling bitcloud
so there's a twitter account that's not
associated with the company
that's insinuating that they're
associated with the company and is about
to make money off of like issuing coins
and stuff
and early users of big cloud are trying
to kind of protect against this
and getting a dose of you know their own
medicine i don't know if arlington
arrington is is involved as an investor
in bitcloud but it was just funny to me
to hear
like bitclout is now facing a situation
where a pseudonymous user
is insinuating that they are like
involved in their company
and they're making money off of it it's
like yeah it sucks it's a terrible way
to
launch a business so yeah i totally
agree i mean
here's the thing i feel like people
listening and even i created a document
where i walked through some some of
these concepts
and some people you know or at least one
person commented something along the
lines of like
the fact that i don't understand crypto
or the blockchain or whatever
one i think you know we may not be
experts but we've done
a little bit of diligence to understand
it at least at a base level
but separate from that this isn't even
just a conversation about
crypto right like crypto obviously or
the blockchain rather underlies this
platform
and of course there are elements that
are very similar to other
financial assets but like i can say
candidly like i'm invested in
in cryptocurrency and i i actually buy
into aspects of that
being the future but not all crypto just
like not all
parts of any innovation are not good and
in this case when you actually
are when crypto is decentralized right
um
and that makes sense when you're talking
about some
some entity just like money right but
when you are talking about people's
reputations that should not be
decentralized because i am centralized
i am a person that that
is impacted by this platform
and therefore as a person if i want to
take myself off the platform
or to take legal action or to do
something
there are reasons that certain things
should be decentralized and certain
things should be centralized to some
extent
right and in this case when you are
actually dealing with people's
reputations
when you may even be breaking some laws
by preceding a platform
um you have to be responsible right
there this is always this fine line
between
centralization decentralization or
something being
um you know anonymous or not
is that anonymity has a lot of
uh good behind it in certain cases
but the kind of counter to that is
always like okay well there where does
the accountability lie
if something is anonymous and as soon as
you go into this again this realm where
you're dealing with other people's lives
that are not anonymous there's got to be
an entity that is responsible for that
and so i agree that again like i just i
something that
maybe bothers me is just people look at
crypto or
anything on a blockchain as very similar
and that the mechanisms
should always apply and that's where i
disagree
um and and i think that in this case
that there should be
like you said something that people can
look to to be responsible the same way
that twitter is responsible for fake
accounts the same way
that all these other platforms are
responsible
for the things happening on their
platform this should also be true
totally agree so tell me this long term
what do what do you think the outcome is
here
i have no idea i think we should quickly
comment on the fact that if people don't
know already there is a lot of money
going into
big cloud and not just from the from the
like uh retail investor perspective but
from
um specific large vc funds so sequoia
um i should actually look this up but i
know sequoyah and dreesen i think
chamoth has
publicly said that he has invested and i
think several other investment firms
but something to keep in mind here
before we get into like what we think is
the future
is that just because you see someone
betting on this especially a venture
capital firm
if you understand the way venture
capital works is they make tons of
bets in the hopes that something becomes
huge
right and most people already know this
but just because
venture capital is investing in this
that just means that they think that
there is
a a chance that this thing can become
big and they're okay if this thing
falters and they actually
just like every other bet they make not
specific to bit clout they expect it to
fail
actually right um they just expect that
one of the many investments that they
make the long shot
happens um so that's something important
to keep in mind in
times of how i view this is i think you
know they're gonna they're gonna add
certain features that
people are talking about a lot right now
they're gonna add a backdoor probably
especially if they're backed by these
these funds um they're going to probably
improve on some of their verification
processes and stuff like that
in terms of where i see it long term
though i'm not sure because i personally
do think that people are going to
realize that betting on people's
reputations doesn't make sense so i
think what you're ultimately going to
see
i think is the evolution of this into
something
very similar to one of the platforms
that exists today if they really focus
on the social aspect
it'll end up being a twitter clone if
they really focus on this like
transfer of value between creators and
in their their audience it's gonna be
more like a sub stack or patreon
if they focus more on this what i
actually think is
a more interesting concept is this idea
of being able to
um to sell part of your
future earnings and really like
incentivize your audience
behind you that's more like an isa right
and you see like
if you've heard of like what's it called
i think it's called big league advance i
think they talked about in my first
million
that's where you know this is already
happening in other industries this is
for for athletes where they basically
give away part of their future earnings
to a company that
that's on them early on so this stuff
already exists but really what i think
is that you're going to see bitcloud
pivot in some way after they make their
initial feature
adjustments and it's going to look like
something that already exists today
and it may succeed and and in that case
like you mentioned earlier that's a
different discussion
right so we're not necessarily saying
big clout forever will be terrible
um or even that it's terrible today but
just
the long-term view of its current
trajectory has some
very serious questions that's a great
way of putting it
yeah and to piggyback on something you
mentioned with the investment i think
there's um
two things worth calling out for anybody
who hasn't
looked closely at this yet and again i
i'll fully admit i may be
misinterpreting things here so if i'm
doing the math wrong or something like
that
shout us out and like we're i would i
would also
give one more disclaimer which is like
we're both in media i am more than
willing to bring on the founder of this
and let them
speak their full uh piece if they want
to
right somebody's willing to come forward
and discuss some of these
potential questions by all means i'm not
this is not meant to be a takedown this
is just some of the things that are
like occurring to me and if there's
legitimate plans in place to curb them
then we want to hear about it so
that's the case in in terms of the
initial investment there are some things
that are worth calling out so
as you mentioned vcs are getting into
this like
one question that steph and i both asked
many times is
what are we missing right there's so
many smart people who are investing in
this
there's no way they haven't thought of
these potential downsides there's just
no way
okay so one thing to know obviously what
you said
there a lot of these people are just
taking a lot of bets also
financially speaking if you look at the
way the value of
bitcloud scales you'd kind of have to be
insane as a vc
not to get involved in this so here's
the deal if you read the the one pager
the
the value of the bitcloud currency
the the base currency on which this
entire model is built it doubles with
every
million coins that are sold um
if you do the math again i might be
doing this wrong but according to
this tracker that like tracks the size
of the website right now there's about
172 million dollars
worth of uh money that's tied up in
creator accounts
okay so that means it's 172 million
us dollars that people have so far
actually used to buy creator coins
if you divide that the current cost of
bitcoin is 149 bucks
so if that 172
represents all of the money that's
currently on the platform that means
there's about a million
of these big coins that has been created
1.1 million
um so long story short there's a million
coins
i couldn't even be wrong maybe maybe
that's only 50 of the value let's say
i'm 50
wrong and there's two million coins the
value of this coin goes up it doubles
every time another million coins is sold
and the company says in their white
paper that they're expecting about
10 to 19 million coins to be created
first of all it's a pretty big gap
but let's say it just goes to 10 right
if you do if you run the math out on
this i feel like i'm
talking about a lot of numbers here but
um
if if it goes up to 10 million coins and
there's currently
say 2 million in existence that means
there's going to be seven more doublings
of the value
of a bit clout coin
which could be huge potential upside for
anybody who invested early
money your money will literally double
seven times i hate to say that because
it sounds like
it's not investment advice all right
okay now
let's look at why the vc firms may have
gotten involved right
maybe they really believe in this but if
you do the math out there were
two million coins that were set aside uh
pre-pre-launched for the founders and
the investors which
uh is a potential value
of 534 billion
dollars by the time 10 million of these
coins have been
issued you know what stuff maybe i
should just share my screen real fast
talk do you think i should share my
screen talk through this real quick
or no is this making no i think it made
sense i think the main takeaway is
the idea that so typically when you get
into something early especially as an
investor
you see the upside of that platform in
terms of
like how many people like the revenue
that it's doing and in here just in the
way that the
the bitcoin is structured it's like you
because of the scarcity getting in early
matters even more
right and that's why you see people
rushing to it not just investors but
just
this idea of if i get an early not only
is this like
i'm not calling it a ponzi scheme but
you know in a typical ponzi scheme you
benefit from someone else under you
doing what you're doing and then selling
it to more people this is like that or
has similar mechanisms where
not only do you benefit from other
people you know who come after you
but because of this the way that the
coin is structured and how it doubles
um and and similar with crater coins
your upside is even more lucrative
right and that's what i think you're
getting at is this idea where it's
not even judging anyone for doing this
but just as you get into anything
ask the question why is someone else
sharing this right
is it because like if i share a link to
an article it's probably because i read
the article and was like
this is so great i think i want you to
share in the value
and maybe there's an element of that
where someone is saying this is so great
i invested early i also want you to
invest early
to share in this upside but there's an
element to this where if i share an
article with you there's no upside for
me other than maybe like
feeling good about myself right and this
there's very clear upside
of someone who got in early whether it's
an investor or someone who just happened
to create their own coin or someone who
happened to invest in another coin like
we talked about ryan beagleman investing
in
sam in in austin so that's really
important just always ask yourself
what are what are the incentives of
someone sharing this and here i think
that
you know we talked about the growth hack
and these incentives and this platform
in the way that they like
they set this up to grow they literally
they designed it
for growth so it was so intelligent but
then it does make me question
you know typically when you see a
platform grow it's because people are
getting
value from the platform and what it
provides
and in this case in the way that the
incentives are structured
it really does make me question um you
know
is it is it really just because people
have been incentivized
in this way it's just something to be
aware of right sure
yeah yeah so these these you know two
million coins were set aside in the
beginning for these investors at this
point right now today
if they can pull that money back out
based on the price of bitcoin
right now that's worth 300 million bucks
and
if it continues to grow up to the 10
million coins that they expect to issue
the uh you know the value of 2 million
coins will be somewhere in the nature of
534 billion
so that's tremendous potential upside uh
the other thing that comes to mind too
when i think about early investors
getting into this
i don't know if this is the case but it
strikes me
that the way they launch this
is extremely dubious right so it's
possible that the investors
bought in in order to protect themselves
because like this is another thing that
can happen right because the value of
the coin scales in a certain way
if you understand how the value of the
coin scales
you can set up a blockade against
character assassination by just
buying enough of your own coin to drive
the prices up so that most people
can't buy it you could buy like a pretty
significant chunk of your own coin if
you have the resources
and uh would it would just drive the
price up so high that you would
own the vast majority of the coins that
will ever be issued for you
these mega firms maybe that's what they
did who knows i don't know if if they
really believe in the idea or if they
did it as like a potential
protection against you know future
downside
that just happens to come with enormous
potential upset that i i don't judge
it like when you look at the potential
cash out of this
i don't judge anybody that did it
because it makes perfect sense turning a
few million bucks into billions and
billions of dollars
is literally why they exist so
that makes a lot of sense but it's worth
remembering that
you know saying that every major
investment firm is involved in this is
kind of like saying
that every major influencer is involved
in this the company didn't give anybody
a chance
to opt out so it's worth questioning
that initial
assessment as well um long term in terms
of what i think is going to happen
here's what i think is going to happen
uh similar to what you're saying i i i
actually don't think this
platform will disappear forever i think
the people behind it
and the like the incentives are too
strong
this is a genie that got out uh i do
think
that we're overvaluing
uh people's willingness to interact with
creators
and so i don't i i don't necessarily
think that's gonna be a long-term
feature
i think we're also overestimating the
willingness of creators to stay on the
platform so here's what i think is going
to happen
i think all the prices are going to
continue to run
up for the next couple of months while
people get involved then at some point
they're going to stabilize
and at the same time
ostensibly the company is creating a way
for people to get their money out
right once two things happen i think
you're gonna start to see people migrate
back off this
and it's the platform's gonna have to
pivot in order to continue to survive
if people can get their money out i
think it's gonna be a mass
migration off as like you said um
creators are just forced to deal with
the downside of this right but also
once that upshot stabilizes and like
this becomes more like a typical stock
ticker where you're not really
increasing your holdings on a regular
basis
oh and you're potentially even
decreasing them i think
the upside is small enough and the
downside is big enough that you're going
to see people migrate back off the
platform and
bitcloud's got some time to pivot
between now and then they're going to
have to in order to survive
but five years from now i don't think
we're gonna be talking about a stock
market for people
um i i think there's something else
related to that the last thing i'll say
and this is the last sentence
or the second to last sentence in the
white paper is
um let's see what does it say here
in the same way that you can move
bitcoin from one wallet to another
bitcloud makes it so that you can move
your clout
in the form of your followers posts
creator coin balances etc
anywhere as well um thus in some sense
bitcloud is decentralizing social media
much the same way bitcoin decentralized
the financial system
if anybody is involved from these major
vc's
that genuinely believes in this idea i
think this is probably why
they did it i don't i don't think most
like
rigorous thinkers look at the idea of
trading on people's
reputations as like a good concept
but this idea of being able to move your
clout from place to place
may not be great but it's better than
what we've got in terms of
social media today character
assassination all that kind of stuff
this is an important feature it's
something that needs to be developed and
it's possible that this whole bit clout
betting scheme is just what was needed
in order to kind of get the more
important thing into the world
so in five years if it still exists i
think that will be the form that it
takes
decentralized social media will be much
more popular
but the idea of betting on reputation
like a lot of people are going to get
hurt in the meantime i think in terms of
the financial incentives here
yeah i would just i think i totally
agree with that i think this idea of
decentralized social media has
merit i think the problem today is
again there are some great ideas here
and if implemented
uh clearly i would say is is the
important part
right transparently where people know
what they're getting there's some real
merit here
that just doesn't exist today and
the problem again when you're when
you're dealing with people's money is
that today big clout
has a little trouble iterating in the
way that
something like twitter would because
twitter can just you know there's no
if they launch a feature and it doesn't
work they launch another one
but there's so much baked in money
already baked into this the way that big
clout runs today
and it's gonna be hard to pivot it as i
was saying i do actually think there's
there's
merit to this idea where you can have
your own coin and there's benefits that
people have but again it's very similar
to something like a patreon or a sub
stack
and the market caps for these people
or i would should say that the largest
ones just don't make sense
right relative to if you were actually
to pivot to
something more like a sub stack or a
patreon so i just think
it's interesting to see how big cloud
has launched and it's gonna be
interesting to see how they
maybe pivot or maybe don't pivot but if
they need to pivot
what happens to the existing coins and
what are they worth and
you know i just think that is gonna be
interesting to watch for sure but i
guess the
the thesis there's a train um the thesis
i think
that we were trying to get at in this
conversation which hopefully came across
is not that like big cloud is
is binary bad or good or anything like
that
but if you're going to participate
whether you're a creator yourself and
you want to
you know create your own coin or you
want to speculate
do what you want to do right obviously
this is not financial advice there's no
judgment here
but think through past today and what
what it exists as
and what this may look like and if you
really want to participate
in that or not even from an ethical
perspective but like
where where do you see this going as an
investment because it's not so clear-cut
as it is today when the system is
literally structured
so that things can only go up absolutely
all right enjoy uh i guess we'll leave
you with
one piece of advice that i always say is
just never invest
in something you don't fully understand
so do your diligence even if this sounds
like something similar
like a stock market for people do your
diligence to understand what it is and
where you think it's going to go
i like that a lot and then the the last
thing that comes to mind for me with
this
is uh i think it's charlie munger and
warren buffett are both big on this
concept of how
trust is your really only long-term
asset and if people think more about
that
they'll they will make different
decisions i think
than if you only focus on the financial
upside so
get out there good luck
i don't know let us know where we're
wrong
we'll hear from you you know where to
find us all right
see ya